We Begin then with the latest violent
confrontations between Israel and
Palestinian fighters in Gaza a sixth
commander of the Islamic Jihad armed
group has been killed in a targeted
Israeli airstrike in central Gaza at
least 33 Palestinians and one Israeli
have been killed since Tuesday heavy
fire continues to be traded despite
international calls for a truce
well funerals are being held for some of
the Palestinians killed in the Israeli
airstrikes angry mourners called for the
armed group Islamic Jihad to escalate
rocket attacks against Israel a barrage
of rockets was fired from Gaza on Friday
morning triggering warning sirens in
southern Israel and an illegal
settlement in the occupied West Bank
altazirusaya joins us now live from Gaza
Yuma where are you what's happening
there
yes Adrian I'm here in a master
neighborhood this is in the central Gaza
City it's one of the most densely
populated areas in Gaza City and um I'm
here this is where the latest Israeli uh
airstrike targeted a residential
apartment I'm stepping away from the
frame so that you can uh see it in
camera now uh here uh
still teams of the defense teams and
emergency teams are still there uh
people have been evacuated from this
building though and uh as you can see
it's a six-story building the targeting
happened in the fifth floor but the
sixth floor and the fourth floor have
been uh widely and badly
also destroyed from that targeting now
we're talking about an assassination
also operation here where these people
were not warned to get out of their
homes there was no warning there was no
wording missile even fired prior to this
targeting and uh civil defense teams and
medical teams have spoken about uh
evacuating uh over 10 people who have
been injured most of them have been
critically or seriously injured while uh
the health Ministry has confirmed two
people killed from the latest uh yeah
targeting here bringing the number to a
total of 31 people killed at over 110
injured you have not six commanders of
Islamic Jihad have are now dead after
these targeted attacks what does this
latest attack mean for the leadership of
the art group
yes well we while we're we're hearing a
lot of news about uh negotiations going
on International pressure going on for
mediation uh the Striking has been uh
very strong today uh now with this
assassination operation we still don't
know if it's just one Islamic Jihad
member in that assassination or both
where off alcott's brigades uh members
so we're still trying to confirm if the
number is six or even more uh to be
killed from them but this shows that uh
there's a an ongoing escalation between
both sides uh the firing of the the
Rockets is not stopped from the Gaza
Strip and this shows that mediations are
not going very well uh it seems that uh
also the the the the general mood in
Gaza is very tense it's very high among
the people everyone is talking about not
having a a very uh fruitful negotiation
of a a very soon ceasefire it seems you
have not many things Indeed Resume live
in Gaza well villain Marx is in Ashkelon
near the border with Gaza and has more
of the situation there
we can hear some of those air strikes in
the distance above us right now you'll
hear drones throughout the course of the
day and every few minutes there will be
the sound of some interceptions by the
Iron Dome defense mechanism every few
minutes I think is a fair way of putting
it maybe every 10-15 minutes you'll see
some attempted rocket launches from Gaza
that will be intercepted for the most
part however not all of them being
intercepted we now know that there have
been direct strikes of rockets on homes
in the city of steroch just a few
kilometers away from me yesterday we had
strikes very close to us here they seem
now to be much more focused on Sarat
does seem a number of homes that have
been damaged they have said over the
course of the last 24 hours the Israeli
military and the Israeli government they
are in a position to strike back local
media reporting that what they'd like to
see and this is according to channel 12
here one of the major news stations here
in Israel they'd like to see this is Mr
netanyahu's aim to try and end the
leadership of Islamic Jihad to continue
to Target the commanders as they have
been for the last few days
let's speak to Jennifer Austin she's
deputy director of operations in the
Gaza field office for the United Nations
relief and works agency or unra she
joins us now live via Skype from Gaza
good to have you with us Jennifer how
has this escalation of violence impacted
upon unrest operations in Gaza food
distribution health and sanitation
services and so on
well thanks Adrian and that's your aware
we're now in today for the ongoing
escalation and the humanitarian
situation is already dire
um from under his perspective we've been
continuing our food program our food
distribution
um our sanitation in the camps our
health centers 22 health centers are
still operating our water wells we're
trying to keep as much operations going
as we can but it's a really bad
situation coming on top of 15 years of
blockade of physical economic and social
blockade and actually the coping
mechanisms of the people here of the
refugees is very dire the situation is
dire here thank you you must be pretty
concerned about the Safety and Security
of your people working on the ground
there and what is the mood of the
general population there in Gaza right
now what are people telling you
um well people here are not very hopeful
and the people
the people are
are really at the as I said that they're
at the end of their coping mechanisms
they have actually
um this is how they feel Adrian
what is unrecalling on all parties
involved to do right now and wants its
message to the International Community
well owner was calling on all parties to
cease and and they should be a ceasefire
of course and we've been waiting for
this hearing about a ceasefire for a
long time now for a few days we're
calling on all parties to protect all
civilians um in particular children and
women have been particularly affected by
this
um it's a really
um
humanitarian disaster in the making tell
us Jennifer tell us Jennifer more about
about what unra is actually doing there
on the ground in in uh so what's what's
it what is it it's work entail
is providing humanitarian assistance for
the
Palestinian
Refuge so that's the 1.7 million
refugees and at the moment as I said we
are running our schools are not
operating so there's 291 000 children
are not going to school because it's too
dangerous we don't we've we don't have
safety to be able to send our children
to school so there's the the girls and
children so
um we're offering schools
um Healthcare and 22 Health Centers
relief and Social Services
um we've had a big uptake in the um uh
first aid hotlines for psychological
Health there's a huge mental health gaps
here and there's a big Mental Health
crisis so I think that's how the
humanitarian situation is going Adrian
but as far as what under is doing as
well we're actually prepared
um if this situation goes further we
have got
um our emergency plans in place our
protocols in place we have um Escape we
can scale up for 150 000 displaced
persons if that happens we've got
emergency food and non-food
ready for those people if they feel
unsafe we've got people coming into our
shelters because they're feeling unsafe
at night or maybe their shelter was
destroyed so it's a really dangerous
situation for the people of Gaza and
they don't feel safe where can they go
to be safe they're coming to the unura
schools coming to our designated
Emergency Shelters and that's where
they're getting safety
really good to talk to you Jennifer many
thanks indeed for being with us Jennifer
Austin there from Gaza